gee mr. pigeon mom I want to ask you
first of all about your characterization
your understanding of the EU as an
organization that always protects itself
and the treatment it is showing towards
the United Kingdom and also how its
supported Madrid in your battle for
Catalonian independence yes for
everything you are right the mockery
European democracy must be improved
because we expect not a clear support in
our fight for independence but the clear
support the clear commitment from the
European Union institutions to our
fundamental rights which are clear
violated from a state member as a Spain
and when you see what you hear in the UK
I know how to give a talk and when you
see how how difficult the European Union
is making it for the UK to follow
through on its own fully legal
referendum and leave do you see similar
characteristics there from the European
Union yes in in some point of view yes
of course
as a pro European people we don't like
brexit but is also bad news not only for
UK but for European Union and no deal or
not good deal but that shows European
Union is probably a very good successful
economical project but not a political
one in political point of view the
European Union must be improved in a
very good way than these days can
explain us and we hope we hope the both
sides can be the best for achieve good a
good deal is only in our interest in the
Catalan interest to see a European Union
more committed to fundamental values
fundamental rights
and find an agreement with the United
Kingdom
is also not a matter of economics but
also Democratic Democratic are you sure
democratic goals perhaps the better
parallel learner in the United Kingdom
is the previous referendum that was held
on these shores on Scottish independence
and the warning that the EU made to
Scotland which of course wants to stay
in the European Union a similar one to
Catalonia that if you secede you would
have to reapply as a third country well
that is not exactly true technically
technically yes but in fact we are
member of the European Union and only we
mask to apply as a new member once
Spanish Kingdom has recognised Catalonia
as an independent state but if that
succeeded that is a scenario that means
we have arrived with the Spanish Kingdom
in agreement a friendship agreement
concerning the depth concerning the
assets the borders the citizenship and
of course if Spain recognized Catalonia
as an independent state that is a show
that shows a very friendship agreement
and ISM interest of the both sides side
for Spain also Catalonia that Catalonia
which is a positive contributor to the
uu budget remains as a member of that
European Union and can I just ask you
lastly mr. Piermont term is it your
intention to try to return to Catalonia
at some point or are you effectively in
exile
well I living in exile in Belgium I am a
free man I am a free European citizen
with a freedom to travel for example I'm
here in London and I was in five
countries after my four months in
Germany but of course if I returned to
Catalonia I will be arrested immediately
so it's not in my next plans to return
in Kotori but I'm fighting for that I'm
fighting every day I wake up every day
saying that is my last day in exile
because if I return that will explain we
will be free we will be a free nation in
the free citizens and that is a good
news not only for Catalonia but it's a
good news also for Spain ok mr. Peachum
thank you very much indeed very good to
talk to you